une chute de 10°r pour ce début de mois
de janvier après un climat plutôt doux
pour les fêtes de fin d'année les
températures sont basse météo France a
annoncé une alerte neige et verglas qui
a pris faim à 13h la région
d'Île-de-France reste en vigilance jaune
grand froid au moins jusqu'à demain
mardi 8 janvier dans les ivelines ce
temps en dessous des normales
saisonnières n'a pas décourager les
coureurs du premier marathon de France
organisé par cerner la ville dimanche 7
janvier ça s'est très très bien passé
mieux que je pensais à part le vent en
fait qui qui ralentit beaucoup
évidemment et un peu de froid au départ
mais sinon super fait très froid j'ai
des problèmes cardios donc voilà je suis
hyper contente ça monter le cardio du
coup faut ralentir un peu pour le WC
puis après il faut continuer quoi une
baisse de température surnommée Moscou
Paris provoqué par une masse d'air
glaciale provenant de Russie et d'Europe
du Nord ce phénomène se caractérise par
par un temps sec et rude sur les
ivelines comme enfésol France on a des
l'air froid qui est arrivé donc avec le
retour des gelés pour cette journée de
lundi généralisé il y a même pas de
dégel dans la journée donc les
températures ne dépassent pas 0°gr en
réalité même - 1 degr on a du mal à
dépasser cette valeur et et on va se
rester donc sous ces nuages et avec
peut-être de petites chutes de neige
également la nuit prochaine avec des
températures qui sont de l'ORD de - 2 3
degr demain matin mercredi 10 janvier
sera le jour le plus près de la semaine
le thermomètre descendra jusqu'à - 5
degrés pour tout le département il
faudra attendre vendredi pour sentir une
légère hausse du
mercure